AND DEMOCRATS.
OH BOY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TODAY.
THANKS.
THE PRESIDENT'S TOP DEFENDERS
ARE OUT WORKING HARD BLAMING
EVERYBODY AND EVERYTHING EXCEPT
FOR HIS OWN POLICIES.
>> IT'S BEEN A ROUGH AND TOUGH
YEAR.
WE KNEW IT WOULD BE.
WE INHERITED A COUNTRY WHERE
4,000 PEOPLE A DAY WERE DYING
FROM COVID.
>> COUNTRY IS IN A BAD PLACE.
WE HAVE A PANDEMIC NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO BRING THE ECONOMY
BACK AND YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE
OTHER THINGS HAPPENING.
SO THE COUNTRY IS IN A BAD
PLACE.
IT IS A TOUGH TIME TO TURN
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Harris: WOW, REALLY?
A PIECE FROM THE HILL WITH THIS
QUOTE.
TODAY'S ELECTION RESULTS
PROMPTED SOME SOUL SEARCHING
AMONG DEMOCRATS WHETHER THE
PARTY MISREAD THE DESIRE FOR
SWEEPING CHANGES.
REPUBLICANS ARE GLAD TO SAY
THEY MISREAD THE MANDATE FROM
BIDEN'S VICTORY A YEAR AGO.
PETE HEGSETH IS CO-HOST OF "FOX
& FRIENDS" WEEKEND.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THERE IS SO MUCH MEAT ON THE
BONE HERE FOR WHAT DEMOCRATS
AND THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T SEE.
LET'S START THERE.
>> YEAH.
WHAT THEY THOUGHT THEY SAW WAS
A MANDATE.
HERE WE ARE A YEAR LATER AND
THEY ARE STILL BLAMING DONALD
TRUMP.
THAT IS NOT LEADERSHIP.
THAT'S MAKING EXCUSES.
IT'S CREATING A STRAW MAN EVEN
THOUGH YOU HAVE ALL THE LEVERS
OF POWER.
COVID, THEY'LL NEVER
ACKNOWLEDGE THE VACCINES THEY
RELY COMPLETELY ON ARE ONES
DELIVERED BY OPERATION WARP
SPEED AND THEY DISMISSED AS
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS BEFORE
THEY BECAME PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WILL NEVER ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
CHINA'S ROLE AND TAKE THEM ON
FOR IT WHEN DONALD TRUMP WAS
WILLING TO DO THAT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
THE FIRST TIME WE'VE TALKED
SINCE THE ELECTIONS LAST WEEK
AND YOU LOOK AT THE PRIORITIES
OF DEMOCRATS VERSUS THE
REALITIES OF AMERICANS, THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED IN VIRGINIA AND
NEW JERSEY AND MINNEAPOLIS.
IN VIRGINIA IT WAS EDUCATION
AND CLASSROOMS.
IN NEW JERSEY IT WAS
OVERWHELMING DRACONIAN COVID
MASK MANDATES AND VACCINE
MANDATES.
IN MINNEAPOLIS WHERE THEY VOTED
AGAINST DEFUNDING THE POLICE IT
WAS ALL ABOUT SIMPLE PUBLIC
SAFETY EVEN THOUGH MINNEAPOLIS
IS A 70/30 DEMOCRAT TO
REPUBLICAN CITY.
SO WHILE JOE BIDEN IS FALLING
ASLEEP IN EUROPE AT WEATHER
CONFERENCES AND PUSHING FOR
ELECTRIC CARS, PEOPLE ARE
HAVING TO FIGURE OUT DO I HAVE
TO WEAR A MASK OR NOT TO PUT IT
ON MY KID?
DO I HAVE TO GET THE VACCINE OR
NOT?
WHAT ARE KIDS BEING TAUGHT IN
THE CLASSROOM AND THE BOARD.
IS CRIME GOING UP IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD?
EVERYTHING IS COSTING MORE FOR
ME IN INFLATION AND THEY CAN'T
EXPLAIN THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS.
SO THESE ARE THINGS THAT HIT
VOTERS WHERE THEY'RE AT.
JOE BIDEN HAS DELIVERED ON NONE
OF THEM.
>> Harris: QUICKLY JAMES
CLYBURN TOP THREE IN POWER IN
THE HOUSE, RIGHT?
HIS OFFICE IS RIGHT NEXT TO
NANCY PELOSI'S.
I'VE BEEN IN THERE.
AND HE SAYS THAT BAD TIME TO
BECOME PRESIDENT.
THEY BROKE A BUNCH OF STUFF IN
THIS COUNTRY LIKE INFLATION,
YET IT IS A BAD TIME FOR BIDEN
TO BE PRESIDENT.
IMAGINE HOW IT IS AS AN
AMERICAN WHO HAS TO GO TO THE
STORE OR THE GAS STATION.
IMAGINE HOW IT IS FOR THEM.
>> THERE IS NO JOE BIDEN
WITHOUT JAMES CLYBURN.
HE HAD THE PIVOTAL RACE IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE KILLING ENERGY
PIPELINES AND WE HAVE RECORD
RELIANCE UPON OPEC AND RECORD
PRICES.
NOW WANT TO KILL ANOTHER
PIPELINE.
LOOK WHAT THEY DID TO THE
BORDER.
PAYING MONEY TO NOT BUILD THE
WALL.
AMAZING.
THEY CREATED THIS.
>> Harris: I WANT TO PAUSE
RIGHT THERE.
HARDLY ANYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT
THE DETAILS OF THIS BUT I WANT
TO.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S ENERGY
SECRETARY SAYS AMERICANS HAD
BETTER BRACE FOR THIS WINTER'S
BILLS.
>> TO THE AMERICANS WILL LIKELY
BE A COLD WINTER.
MOST OF THEM ARE.
EXPECT TO PAY HIGHER PRICES FOR
HEATING THEIR HOMES.
>> THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT WILL BE MORE EXPENSIVE THIS
YEAR THAN LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM IN
FUELS THAT THE SUPPLY CHAINS
HAVE WHICH IS THE OIL AND GAS
COMPANIES ARE NOT FLIPPING THE
SWITCH AS QUICKLY AS THE DEMAND
REQUIRES.
>> Harris: MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
THE YEAR WHEN MOST OF US WERE
LOCKED INSIDE OUR HOMES?
WOW.
A REPORT FROM THE ENERGY
INFORMATION ADMINISTRATION
FINDS WE'LL ALL PAY MORE FOR
EVERYTHING, PROPANE, NATURAL
GAS, PRICE AT THE PUMP.
THE AVERAGE COST OF GASOLINE A
GALLON IS CLOSE TO $5 IN MANY
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
AFTER TAKING HEAT FOR CANCELING
THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE LET'S GET
BACK TO WHAT PETE HEGSETH WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
I ASKED MY TEAM FOR A MAP.
I WANT EVERYBODY TO FOCUS.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING DO THIS
AGAIN AND LOOKING AT SHUTTING
DOWN ANOTHER ENERGY PIPELINE.
THE LINE 5 IN MICHIGAN.
IN A LETTER TO THE PRESIDENT,
13 LAWMAKERS WROTE SHOULD THIS
PIPELINE BE SHUT DOWN?
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS WOULD
BE LOST ACROSS THE REGION AS WE
ENTER THE WINTER MONTHS.
THE TERMINATION OF LINE 5 WILL
FURTHER EXACERBATE SHORTAGES,
PRICE INCREASES AND HOME
HEATING FUELS LIKE NATURAL GAS,
PROPANE AT A TIME WHEN
AMERICANS ARE ALREADY FACING
RAPIDLY RISING ENERGY PRICES.
SAY IT WITH ME.
LINE 5 MICHIGAN.
LET'S GET TO KNOW IT.
PETE.
>> JUST LIKE WE GOT TO KNOW THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE.
RATHER THAN WORK ON ENERGY WITH
CANADA WHO IS A RELIABLE
TRADING PARTNER TO GET OUR
ENERGY SOURCES AND THEN
PREVENTING OUR OWN COMPANIES
FROM EXPLORATION, WHETHER IT'S
FRACKING, NATURAL GAS, ALL OF
THAT.
WE'RE BEGGING OPEC -- BEGGING
OPEC, A CARTEL, TO INCREASE ITS
SUPPLY SO THAT OUR PRICES CAN
GO DOWN WHEN JUST A YEAR AGO AS
YOU LAID OUT, HARRIS, WE WERE
EFFECTIVELY ENERGY INDEPENDENT
HELPING TO DRIVE DOWN GLOBAL
ENERGY PRICES BECAUSE OF THE
SUPPLY WE COULD ADD AND THE
DEMAND WE COULD MEET.
THIS IS DEMOCRATS ALL THEY ARE
DOING IS VOWING TO EXTREMIST
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS SAYING A
PIPELINE LIKE THIS IS UNSAFE TO
THE ENVIRONMENT WHEN I JUST
HAVE A FEELING BASED ON THE
WORKING FOLKS WORKING ON THAT
PIPELINE THEY WILL MAKE SURE
THAT PIPELINE WORKS AND IS NOT
-- DOES NOT LEAK, DOES NOT
CREATE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
AND WE ALL PAY THE PRICE.
54% IN ENERGY PRICE INCREASES
YOU AND I CAN PROBABLY HANDLE
THAT.
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE ON THIS
CHANNEL AND IN THE MEDIA,
THAT'S FINE MAYBE.
THINK ABOUT AN AVERAGE FAMILY
IN THE UPPER MIDWEST GOING
THROUGH A COLD WINTER AND
LOOKING AT 30, 40, 50% INCREASE
IN HEATING AND ENERGY PRICES.
THAT IS A REGRESSIVE TAX
AGAINST THE LEAST AMONG US.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY THEY WON'T
RAISE TAXES ON LOW WAGE EARNERS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS.
>> Harris: I WAS DIGGING DEEPER.
I WILL DO IT ALL WEEK LONG NOW.
ENBRIDGE.
THIS ISN'T THE RIGHT THING TO
DO TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THIS
AND NOT TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE TRUTH ABOUT IT.
DOWN CHAIN SUPPLY CHAIN
PETROLEUM PRODUCTS, IT IS MORE
THAN JUST THE PEOPLE IN THE
UPPER MIDWEST.
WE'LL LEARN.
>> BY THE WAY, HARRIS, THE
ENERGY SECRETARY LAUGHED OPENLY
WHEN ASKED IF SHE HAD A PLAN TO
ADDRESS OUR ENERGY NEEDS.
SHE LAUGHED AND SAID WHAT DO
YOU WANT ME TO DO WAVE A MAGIC
WAND?
WHEN BARACK OBAMA SAID WHAT DO
YOU WANT ME TO DO WAVE A MAGIC
WAND TO BRING BACK
MANUFACTURING JOBS?
DONALD TRUMP FOCUSED ON THAT
AND TRIED TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
THEY'RE DOING THE OPPOSITE.
>> Harris: SECRETARY GRANHOLM
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE MAGIC
WAND.
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" FACED
FEEDBACK.
>> SUICIDE BY COP WAS ELECTED
-- WAS ELECTED AS VIRGINIA'S
FIRST BLACK FEMALE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A WIN FOR
DEMOCRATS.
NOTHING WILL GET REPUBLICANS TO
SUPPORT GUN CONTROL FASTER THAN
THIS PICTURE.
>> Harris: POSTED THE PHOTO IN
RESPONSE TO CRITICISM FROM HILL.
AFTER THEY UPSET DEMOCRATS IN
VIRGINIA LAST WEEK HILL TWEETED
IT'S NOT THE MESSAGING, FOLKS.
THE COUNTRY LOVES WHITE
SUPREMACY.
TEAM WINSOME RESPONDED WITH THE
PHOTO WE BEG TO DIFFER.
>> ALL THE WHITE SUPREMACISTS
WHO VOTED FOR A BLACK
LIEUTENANT FEMALE GOVERNOR.
THE LAUGHTER IN THIS CLUB.
ME AS A SUPPORTER OF THE SECOND
AMOUNT CARES WHETHER IT'S A
BLACK OR WHITE WOMAN.
THEY ARE THE ONES BEING RACIST
ABOUT IT.
WE A GRATEFUL FOR THE SERVICE
OF SOMEONE LIKE MS. SEARS AND
SPEAK THE TRUTH.
NOW THEY SAY SHE IS SPEAKING
WHITE WORDS FROM A BLACK MOUTH.
THEY ARE THE RACISTS IN THE
EQUATION.
I'M NOT LOOKING AT HER RACE BUT
WHAT SHE WILL DO FOR VIRGINIA
AS A CONSERVATIVE.
>> Harris: THAT'S SO TRUE.
PETE HEGSETH.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU IN "FOCUS."
PROGRAMMING NOTE NOW ON THE FOX
NATION APP.
THE PATRIOT AWARDS ARE COMING
UP NEXT WEEK WEDNESDAY,
NOVEMBER 17th AT THE HARD ROCK
LIVE THEATER IN HOLLYWOOD,
FLORIDA.
PETE HEGSETH WILL BE THERE
ALONG WITH OTHER FOX